are only vaccinated people allowed to
vote in germany
this claim about the federal election is
circulating on the net but this is not
true
vitw examined why
let's take a closer look this tweet says
people without a coveted vaccination
cannot vote in germany and are banned
from entering polling stations there is
even talk of electoral fraud
beatrix von steuch an mp from the far
right alternative for germany party
known as afd alleged that the federal
returning officer had also considered
banning unvaccinated people in a
response to his tweet
our unvaccinated people really denied
the right to vote
false
fact is unvaccinated people are allowed
to vote at the polling stations like
everyone else if they observe the
applicable hygiene measures
they can also vote by post
voters have the right to cast their
ballots regardless of their vaccination
status confirms the federal returning
officer to the w
is
[Music]
more than 60 million eligible voters
will be able to elect a new parliament
this year
many germans have one concern
can the election be manipulated through
disinformation
82 percent fear exactly that according
to a survey and more than every second
person has stumbled across politically
motivated fake news online
what can you do about it we will show
you some fakes and also how to recognize
them
let's take the examples of election
posters
they are currently hanging all over
germany but not all of them are real
this one says everyone is talking about
the climate
we are ruining it
a clear fake the cdo confirmed the
poster is not theirs extension rebellion
a group of environmental activists
confirmed that it's their work
this is a special form of so-called
negative campaigning the attempt to
defame political opponents
even if they're meant to be satirical
some might consider the posters to be
genuine
some fake election posters also target
top politicians
cdu's chancellor candidate amin lachet
is misquoted here
flood i can only laugh about that
that's a fake
noise
[Music]
these posters were hanging in some major
german cities and intended to ridicule
the greens and their goals
the greens made it clear it is a fake
both the cdu and the greens party
suspect these are smear campaigns by
political parties like the far right afd
such campaigns often see the false
posters circulate on social media with
some even going viral
most attacks take place digitally and
the greens are particularly affected in
the german election
according to an investigation by the ngo
avas their chancellor candidate analina
bayabak
some of the misinformation circulating
online says that bayabok is planning to
terminate widow pension in order to
accommodate migrants
or this bizarre one that she would ban
pets because they emit carbon dioxide
these are false
bearbach never claimed such things such
claims are not listed in the green's
election manifesto either
amin lashed from the conservative cdu
experienced another political hit he was
wrongly accused of sifting off donations
for germany's flood victims toward his
own election campaign
this claim is also unsubstantiated and
false
the money collected from the donations
has already been partially paid out to
the flood victims
we hardly found any disinformation on
olaf schultz or his party the spd
however some fakes are also directed
against the election itself especially
the postal vote a record number of
postal ballots are expected this year
due to the pandemic
some claim the postal vote is easy to
manipulate
and that someone could also cast a
ballot using the names of dead people
does that sound familiar to you
donald trump and the republicans use
similar rhetoric in the 2020 u.s
presidential election but today there is
no evidence of systemic manipulation of
postal voting
and in germany can postal votes be
easily manipulated
misleading
when voting by post nobody can guarantee
that a voter cast their vote without any
influence from third parties
however the postal ballot itself is
protected against misuse through several
measures
have you come across fakes lately
what should we take a closer look at
next time
let us know in the comments below or by
mail at factchecking dw.com
you